juillet 2014 après la scission avec la
guyane lui âgé laisse place à
l'université des antilles sur ordonnance
elle dispose de deux pôles l'un en
guadeloupe l'autre en martinique
chacun possède un pouvoir décisionnel et
gère de façon autonome l'administratif
les financer l'organisation des
formations une transition brutale pour
corinne mencé casters alors présidente
de l'époque
après cinq ans d'une gouvernance
mouvementée marquée par le scandale du
c'est régulier à un laboratoire de
recherche où se sont joués de nombreux
détournements financiers
elle laisse la place à un stage gens qui
professeur des universités praticien
hospitalier et mérite la question de la
répartition des moyens entre les deux
pôles ressurgit à son arrivée avec des
tensions notamment sur la masse
salariale
la martinique se dit lésé et parle d'un
déséquilibre elle compte pourtant moins
d'étudiants que la guadeloupe 5051
inscrits cette année contre 3642 au
campus de schoelcher des chiffres qui
inspire les contradicteurs des deux
camps et pourrissent les relations entre
les deux régions
dernier fait en date un rééquilibrage
financier de 7 millions d'euros au
profit de la guadeloupe
la menace d'une nouvelle scission
ressurgi dans un dossier où le manque de
dialogue
contraste avec l'essence même d'une
université